what's going on guys this is Rob I know
I'm on vacation I know that I'm taking a
break which I am I'll be back on on
Monday officially but I had to say this
alright I had to tell you guys this I
don't know if any of you guys have been
following agent Carter very closely or
if you were watching the last episode
and even episode before that where they
had the old man who was spinning the
ring on his finger those of you guys who
were in the know know that's one of the
rings of the Mandarin oh man I'm so
psyched that is the that's the one that
he actually has on his ring finger which
he does and that one's called the liar I
think it is and it allows the wearer to
cast illusions in the minds of people
and to put them under their mental
control as soon as he did that like as
soon as he did that to the chief I was
like oh my god is that a ring at the
Mandarin and I was I was like okay let's
see if he doesn't some more I see if he
does it a few more times maybe there's
something else going on it sure enough
he just kept spinning the ring and I was
like oh my god like Marvel is telling us
like the mandarins real like the
Mandarin because I know we saw that one
shot who has her Ben Kingsley where he
was like in prison and the one dude
shows up and he was like the Mandarin
wants you to meet him or something like
that but this this is telling us that
like the rings were around before the
Mandarin became the Mandarin most likely
I'm not really sure that's how the
continuity is gonna play out but
nonetheless that is one of the rings of
the Mandarin I am so psyched okay anyway
that's that's it for my video I will
need to do a video on the Mandarin we
need to do the Mandarin explained so you
guys know what's going on with the ten
ring it's because the Mandarin does
badass he can punch through Tony Stark's
armor he can he has a ten rings to
control like all different kinds of
stuff he's a really really cool guy but
I'm Sol and bidding he'd even keep
messaging me on skype my god man and
anyway I will I'll catch you guys later
peace